Continuing
the chapter of vigilance
authored by
in the narration of
that a man with very white clothing,
very black hair, unknown to everyone
yet not appearing to be a traveler,
entered the masjid, came very close
in his sitting to the prophet
sallall.aii
and asked him a series of questions.
He said,
he said, "Oh, Muhammad, tell me about
Islam."
, define Islam.
Two things to take from this. Number
one,
he addressed him by his first name.
And addressing the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam
by his first name is impermissible
in Islam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
prohibited
that we address the prophet Sam
as we would
any other person amongst us. And so even
his wives and even his closest friends
were to thus address him as
by his.
What is his
or to address him by his title?
And this is why
during his time
during his lifetime saham
it was impermissible
for anyone to carry the same ka.
He was called Abul Kasim because his
oldest child was alasim. His oldest male
child was
and he passed away in his infancy.
And
being that this is the case,
he was always referred to as aim, but it
was not permissible for anyone else to
carry his kuna.
However, it was permissible to name
our children after him. This is during
his lifetime. He says,"
[Silence]
he said, "name your children after me,
yet do not use my kuna for anyone else."
Why? What is the reason for this?
Because
if a person were to call out or address
him and say yeah
maybe if there is more than one Abasim
this person would
if he didn't intend the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam he
intended someone else
let's say he is there with someone and
that other person has the
you come in you say yeah
and so now you have that person and the
prophet sallallam
turning to him
he now is going to have to say
he's going to have to say to the prophet
sall sallallahu alaihi wasallam no it's
not you I was calling it was him over
here right and so this
is an etiquette which is unbefitting of
the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam therefore being that nobody
would be addressing him as by his first
[Arabic recitation]
then it became appropriate to name
children during his lifetime with the
name Muhammad. Appropriate to change
names of people entering to Islam who
have an unacceptable name to be named
Muhammad. This is fine because no one is
saying yeah Muhammad and intending the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam from
amongst his close companions.
And so
many started to name their children
with the name Muhammad. Before that,
very very rare was the name Muhammad
ever used or heard. Very rare. as a
matter of fact, there are only one or
two potential instances where this name
was ever even heard of before his
birth saiam.
People use the word ahmed. They use the
word the name Ahmed but Muhammad was
very rare.
And so this is the first point. The
second point here is that who we'll find
out later is Gibl asked the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam to define him to
define for him Islam.
Who are
men?
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa'tala.
And so the word
it doesn't just mean teach me about
Islam.
He is saying teach me about the
very intricate details of Islam. Not
just what is readily available or
readily known to everyone. Rather what
is a little more advanced or a little
more detailed than that that which is
beyond the superficial and this is the
meaning of alabar
in the
Arabic language and from this is the
name of Allah alab
meaning the one who is has the
knowledge of the intricate
hidden details of all that exists.
And so here he says
so he is asking to get to the crux of
what Islam is.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
responds to this question by
defining Islam
through its most prominent rights.
Just if I were to say to you, tell
me
what
or where is the masid for instance or
what is the masid
and then you go to define the masid to
me by its most prominent features.
It's a building that has a dome. It's at
this street and that street. , it's a
building that is this color, is this
size, etc. That's not necessarily a
definition
of what the masid is. It is a definition
of the most it is giving a definition by
the most prominent of features.
And this is one of the ways of defining
things. that when we define something,
we use its most prominent features to
define it.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam
describes Islam by mentioning its
prominent features of the five pillars
of Islam.
He says,
He says, "Islam
is that you testify
that none is rightfully worship but
Allah and that Muhammad is the messenger
of Allah." These two parts are
considered to be one.
These two parts make up one pillar of
Islam. They are not separate pillars.
And so they come together
are two halves to
the whole which is very important for a
reason we will arrive at later
[Arabic recitation]
and that you establish prayer
and that you give a zaka which is often
translated as almsgiving.
A L M S
Ramadan and that you fast the month of
Ramadan
and that you make pilgrimage to the
house meaning thea the
if you have the ability to do so. if you
have a way of reaching it.
And his response to this answer was
we just took in the previous chapter
that is what
it is being correct. It's not just
telling the truth. Telling the truth is
only one aspect of a a in the Arabic
language in the language of the Quran,
the language of the Sunnah
is that a person is accurate with what
he says. Not just that a person is not
actively lying.
We will pick this up inshallah
and
Alhamdulillah.